de faire appel à une directrice
artistique de renom fait une escale chez
nous entre la fashion week de new york
et celle de paris c'est une amie elle a
la gentillesse de venir ce soir nous
dispenser ses petits conseils venus
applaudir la présence exceptionnelle de
charisma vancamp août
[Applaudissements]
le dire dans ces chiens
vestiaires champagne bon jean luc vous
m'avez introduite
oui c'est bon alors non je vous trouve
très mignon
franchement je vous trouve super je
regarde depuis tout à l'heure c'est
chouette en plus d'habitude j'aime pas
les gens gros donc là c'est bien passé
un truc c'est pas si parce que vous êtes
caché derrière votre comptoir ou si
michel tu me les cadrans comment la en
plan large de loin oui c'est bien un
saccage comme ça qu'ils ont sorti
l'appareil à raclette alors qu'on est en
septembre comment vous la trouvez
l'émission allez tour de table vous êtes
bien vous êtes content ouais j'aime pas
écouter ça fait kermesse verdès pourquoi
vous partez dans les aigus quand vous
vous énervez pas souvent que l'on veut
voix tête si pas bien verdès c'est pas
bien pour vous c'est pas bien pour les
gens les gens appellent ils sont pas
contents ça fait du larsen avec leur
poste de télé non j'aime pas en mangeant
envie de me me voilà j'ai envie de me
crever les tympans avec un big palace à
celle un bon écoutez jean louis ont
tissé bien faire voilà vous lui mettez
un truc dans la bouche on sait rien gold
est jeune mais je ne sais pas trouvé un
truc de l'ormeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
les chèques à son nom qu'il vous plaît
et toc toc toc
non mon dos lors nous attendait là
michel il me dit l'émission ça bah ça
donne envie
ça donne envie de crever on se fait
chier même si c'est pas la perdre est
trouvée nous un petit peu je sais pas
moi enlever votre culotte fait comme à
gâteau proulx est long les femmes les
gens là ça met du peps quoi c'est qui la
dame moustoir non c'est quoi vos
méninges grave c'est ça bon allez jean
luc fait lui un petit gribouillés sur un
paquet là on l'a fait dans le public
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous avez sur les âges
comprend pas assez tout non faussée du
sébum ils n'ont pas fait ça à nos jours
bon jean luc ch
il brille autant que mon pantalon c'est
pas moi c'est pas des pantalons c'est
des chroniqueurs jean luc non ça ne va
pas ça j'aime pas non regardez on dirait
des dos de loup très certainement bien
passé mais qu'est ce qu'on fait abbey
pesait qu'est ce qu'on fait dans l'ue
repoudre ça va nous coûter une tonne
mais voilà c'est pas que sur la zone t
là c'est notre homme de tout l'alphabet
on dirait que vous avez un bond de
l'autre qui attendent le coup de sifflet
pour ont sauté à travers le cerceau
attendez on va faire est-ce que vous
voyez que jean-luc à un cerceau là bas
alors on laisse tomber cette idée de
gras non non non un mini bain mais voilà
mais ça c'est mon petit pilier elle est
toujours à prêter
elle est mignonne regardez c'est
intemporel c'est quoi un c'est facile à
enlever c'est pas
chut c'est que confort oui mais oui
voilà on habitait à la retraite ou non
les super oui vraiment mais pourquoi tu
m'as pas vous ne m'avez pas mis castaldi
s'habille toujours bien oui à mon
benjamin mais je t'adore
benjamin s'il te plaît tu me la fait
tremper cette culotte de la ménagère
[Rires]
écoute moi bien je veux qu'elle se noie
c'est quoi
allô oui non j'ai pas le temps chez avec
des gens qui mangent de la raclette
banon mais c'est pas évident non oui ils
n'obéissent commence à cyril est resté
collé mais commence à cyril est restée
collée au mur dans un couleurs tropez 3
mais oui ça colle la gomina
non mais c'est pas bon et les gens lui
que vous me les repoudrer d'accord vous
me les machins vous prenez des notes
jojojura il faut qu'on travaille son
look l'aspirine caravane chic
[Applaudissements]
c'est que les grands les miliaires
taponier
[Applaudissements]